[Musique]
zone Europe sur sensation
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans zone
Europe sur Radio sensation et sur TV 78
une émission spéciale aujourd'hui
enregistrée à Cannes à l'occasion du 76e
festival voici le sommaire
on fera le point sur l'industrie du
cinéma où se situe les pays européens
qui tirent son épingle du jeu vous
verrez le programme Europe créative
ensuite aide l'industrie
cinématographique européenne on en
discutera avec Céline lambranco membre
du bureau Europe créative France
l'Espagne à l'honneur cette année au
marché du film le pays s'est distingué
avec plusieurs prix au festival de
Berlin et Pedro Almodovar présente un
nouveau court-métrage cette année à
on parlera aussi du prix luxe un prix
organisé par le Parlement européen pour
encourager la créativité
cinématographique
[Musique]
zone Europe sur sensation
bonjour bonjour vous êtes membre du
bureau Europe créatif France alors le
programme Europe créative c'est un
programme européen donc de l'Union
européenne qui aide les secteurs
cinématographiques et audiovisuel
européen à promouvoir concevoir et
distribuer les films européens les
œuvres européennes dans le monde entier
comment est-ce que ce dispositif comment
Europe créative fonctionne-t-il alors
comme vous l'avez dit le programme
Europe créative va aider tout d'abord à
concevoir les films dans un premier
temps et aller promouvoir à travers
toute une série de d'aide donc il y a
17h de médias et donc on va être du
début de la programmation jusqu'à la
promotion vraiment la distribution le
soutien au sale au distributeur au
festival par exemple le Marché du Film
de Cannes par le Programme MEDIA l'idée
c'est aussi de
promouvoir les échanges entre les
différentes
production européenne par exemple la
France avec l'Allemagne avec l'Italie
en quoi ça peut être important en termes
de compétitivité par rapport au cinéma
notamment américain avec les États-Unis
et le Canada oui alors le
l'idée du programme média et bien sûr de
de faire travailler ensemble des
partenaires du secteur audiovisuel et
cinématographique européen et notamment
des pays plus fortes capacités de
production comme le son l'Allemagne ou
la France avec des pays dit affable
capacité de production par exemple les
Balkans et on voit de plus en plus de
projets de coproduction entre les grands
pays et les petits pays et c'est ce qui
unit aussi les forces et après créer des
œuvres un niveau européen qui vont
pouvoir circuler en Europe bien sûr et à
travers le monde que ce soit des projets
de fiction d'animation ou de
documentaires donc ce programme si je
résume il y a une partie réseau est-ce
qu'il y a aussi une partie aide
financière pour pour les différents
films et si oui comment est-ce que ces
aides sont attribuées qui choisit et qui
les sélectionne alors donc je vous
disais le programme Europe créative
c'est toute une batterie de d'aide qui
vont de vraiment de la conception donc
d'aider des projets en développement
jusqu'à la sortie du film en salle donc
vraiment toute la chaîne et donc
indirectement de la présence ici et d'un
marché à Cannes et bien vous allez avoir
des possibilités de participer à des à
des ateliers ça va soutenir aussi des
formations des network tels que Ace ou
ave pour les producteurs et les
productrices ça peut être intéressant et
pour si on prend le cas des sociétés de
production il faut être une société de
production européenne indépendante et et
voilà vouloir travailler coopérer avec
ses partenaires européens alors dans le
cadre de ce dispositif on est ici au
Festival de Cannes est-ce qu'il y a eu
des films qui sont présentés ici qui ont
qui ont bénéficié de ce dispositif alors
cette année à Cannes on a 14 films
médias en compétition donc quatre qui
concourent pour la Palme d'Or et parmi
ces quatre films médias on peut dire que
trois
sont réalisés par des femmes donc voilà
on a la chimère ou quatre filles et qui
sont cette année en compétition
enfin pour finir un petit comparatif sur
les pays européens et le cinéma quels
sont les pays qui produisent le plus de
films justement cocorico la France et le
pays le plus soutenu voilà après on a un
grand tissu un grand marché de un grand
réseau de cinéma audiovisuel ici et donc
voilà traditionnellement c'est la France
qui est le pays le plus soutenu mais
voilà Satan un peu quand même à aller
vers d'autres marchés et on s'ouvre un
peu justement comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure vers les pays de l'Est les
Balkans et voilà mais français Allemagne
le couple qui reste traditionnellement
le plus soutenu et c'est logique c'est
en France aussi qui a lieu ce festival
de Cannes merci
je rappelle donc que vous êtes membre du
bureau Europe créative France
[Musique]